The first thing you notice about Michael
Mann's heat is that it's all long lenses
in a widescreen 23 by nine format meant
to allow for a broad scope so that you
can see more man crowds,
his subjects into the frame as if you
were always watching them on a stakeout
from some hidden vantage on the building
opposite the telephoto Lens is really
the perfect lens for this film.
It has the effect of keeping everything
at a distance all at the same time,
separating people from the background
while also at the same time turning the
background into an almost liquid plane
of lights.
Evoking that fantastical romance that is
always found in new war and which
Michael Mann seeds in the sprawl of Los
Angeles.
This is all to say that the telephoto
Lens is both functional and stylistic
and he two words that could be used to
describe the driving ethos behind man's
work.
Of course,
style is never something Michael Man's
been accused of.
In fact,
it's likely accusations of empty
stylistics from the days of Miami vice
that made man insist that he wasn't a
genre film at all,
but it drama drawn from the stories of a
real life detective who served as a
consultant on the film,
and it's true,
the procedural and mundane elements of
police and criminal activity are
painstakingly rendered and heat and
there's a pride in the fact that the
locations are real locations in La.
This was an actual cardboard community
on terminal island.
This train that the neuro gets out of
his,
the Real Blue Line of the Los Angeles
Mta and his house is a real house in
Malibu by the sea,
but man can't hide his knack for and
devotion to style.
The three locations I mentioned may be
real places,
but it's not an accident that in the
first a giant mound of yellow sulfur
gives the space a dreamlike quality or
that the train platform feels both alien
and alienating.
And as for Deniros home,
what could call attention to itself more
than this blue suffused box of
loneliness cribbed from Alex Coleville,
1967 painting Pacific.
In other words,
despite Michael Mann's protestations,
that this is not a genre piece,
he is clearly drawing from both crime
and the war traditions.
What makes the film brilliant is that,
uh,
uses its style and realism to comment on
each other,
and in doing so,
updates the genre for a new age.
A lot of this is done through sound in
the film by the great work and Chris
Jenkins sound design and Elliot Golden
Falls Score.
The interplay is established right at
the start as golden falls,
spacey,
highly stylized score fades into the
hyper real sounds of a hospital and that
exchange is in the soundtrack for the
scene where Pachino chases down to near
on the highway man uses a joy division
song called new dawn feeds that has a
driving rhythm that gets the moment
perfect.
But what I just played,
that's actually not the song used in the
movie,
man commissioned a cover of new dawn,
fades by the electronic artists,
moby who super adds to this functional
moment,
a layer of pure style.
Listen to the difference.
Since its beginning,
there has been a tension and feel new
war between realism and style.
It's origins in black and white and
harsh chiaroscuro lighting attempted to
communicate a gritty realism,
but in this lady in the implicitly
abstract nature of black and white,
it created a style all its own.
It's values,
however,
we're always traditional from the start
and the war has investigated the way men
construct their identities from what
they do that reflected the broad scope
of men in the early 20th century,
not just cops and robbers,
but the rise of postmodern consumerist
culture of new ways to build identity
that weren't from one's career or one's
relationships made,
the crime films association with style
more problematic,
but also more necessary.
Man Confronts this head on with Deniro
and Chinos characters,
Deniro style,
his slick suits his minimal empty house,
reflect his lifestyle of extreme
professionalism,
matched in the actual culture of the
eighties when the film was first
conceived,
but Geno tube is placed in the actual
home of postmodern architect.
Thom Mayne in Santa Monica man knows
that to communicate with contemporary
audiences,
to make a crime noir that is fresh and
looks forward,
these stylistic choices have to be
present.
Modern audiences firmly entrenched in
this culture register style.
They speak themselves through style and
it's through this attention to style
that he can finally level a critique on
its own culture.
In the end,
Deniro and Pachino ultimately reject
these new forms of identity
construction.
You can lounge around here on her sofa
in her ex husband's dead tech,
post modernistic bullshit house if you
want to,
and they fall back on traditional
methods,
but Chino looks to his work and Deniro
looks to relationships.
There's no point in going anywhere
in this way.
Michael Man's to style in score,
in soundtrack,
in lenses,
in locations,
in wardrobe,
in lighting,
and his attention to realism in all
those same categories.
Serve to illustrate a new social
environment as well as its drawbacks and
that's what Phil knew aura was always
meant to do at its best show the
underside of culture and why it's
unnecessary.
Extension of the reverse.
In fact,
it may be the case in our modern culture
that when the two sides are put face to
face,
they don't look all that different.
Hey everybody,
thanks for watching.
He is one of the best crime thrillers of
all time.
No question about that.
I just want to say that 2015 has been
the best year of my life.
Uh,
you guys have helped me expand this
channel to something that I never could
have imagined that a fact that I get to
do this full time is just beyond my
wildest dreams.
I believe in this channel so much.
And when the work that's happening here
and I really believe that to exist in
2016 and beyond,
it has to innovate and experiment and do
new things.
And that is what I'm looking forward to
doing and looking forward to giving to
you.
There's a really special relationship
between the people who watch this
channel pleasure,
this channel on my patrion page and me
because there's nothing in between us.
And that's a model that I talk about
after every video.
But one that I really,
really,
really believe in because this content
is not diluted by any corporation or any
brand or anything like that.
And that's,
I think,
really special and I think a new model
for the way that content can be.
So,
um,
I just want to say thank you for 2015.
You guys have been awesome.
If you do want to pledge,
you can click right there and go to my
picture on page.
Um,
I will see you guys next Wednesday in
2016 and hopefully an exciting year to
come.